the falcon in the winter soldier puts
anthony mackie and sebastian stan
center stage as the mcu sam wilson and
james bucky barnes
the story spotlights these sidekicks as
they work to find their place in a
post-captain america world
here's how it begins and what that
shocking ending means
right off the bat the falcon in the
winter soldier puts the spotlight on sam
wilson aka
the falcon and his difficult decision to
leave captain america's shield behind
he packs it up before the episode jumps
to his work with the united states
military
wings and all sam rescues one of the
military's liaisons from an organization
known as
laf of which the often forgotten mcu
villain george batroc
aka backrock the leaper is a part don't
remember him
he was in winter soldier this is him
getting punched right here
sam's mission against the laf is a
success though not without plenty of
close calls
and then the episode moves us to a
presentation at the smithsonian
institution where sam hands over cap's
shield so that it can be put on display
in a museum
we need new heroes
one suited for the times we're in as the
audio in the opening scene reminds
viewers when steve rogers hands sam the
captain america shield at the end of
avengers end game
sam admits that he feels it belongs to
someone else
steve does his best to convince sam that
it belongs to him now and
sam is honored to take it but it's clear
he's not prepared for the responsibility
later on he explains to james war
machine roads that captain america's
shield is synonymous with steve
and steve alone it's implied that sam
would rather give it up
instead of possibly making a mockery of
its legacy considering how much both sam
and bucky respect steve it's reasonable
to assume
one or both of them will get a hold of
the shield by the end of the series
at one point or another in the pages of
marvel comics they both take on the
captain america mantle so
surely the falcon and the winter soldier
wouldn't pass up the opportunity to do
the same
the first episode does a keen job of
planting the seeds for this possible
plotline
and fans will simply have to wait and
see how it all blooms in future episodes
while sam wilson is working to protect
the country without the captain american
name
bucky barnes the one time winter soldier
is attempting to get used to life as a
civilian
the us government is pardoning him for
his crimes as the winter soldier so
he's in self-imposed isolation and
working through his past trauma and
therapy
i just went from one fight to another
for 90 years
the results have been mixed at best
thanks to bucky's apparently frequent
nightmares about his former life as a
brainwashed assassin
despite becoming friends with the
elderly mr nakajima and dipping his toe
into both the virtual
and physical dating worlds bucky can't
seem to escape his past
his time as hydra's human weapon haunts
him rendering him lonely once again
in many ways this depiction of bucky's
new life makes him the antithesis of
captain america when he came out of the
ice
steve was welcomed into the modern world
assigned to the avengers team and
hailed as a hero for years making many
new connections along the way
on the other hand bucky is left to his
own devices and lacks the ability to
meaningfully connect with other people
after
years of having his mind controlled it's
good that he received no punishment for
the atrocities he committed as the
winter soldier but
he didn't get much else it's a sad state
to be in especially since bucky's past
makes him relatively incapable of moving
forward on his own even though we
learned during his therapy session that
he's been ducking sam's phone calls it's
safe to assume that the falcon in the
winter soldier will show bucky reuniting
with his longtime frenemy which will
mark a huge turning point in bucky's
otherwise lonely and
uneventful life the teasers and trailers
have shown us that bucky and sam will
embark on some seriously heart-pumping
adventures as they battle the bad guys
with any luck these missions will not
only prove to bucky how capable he is as
a hero but also bring him some strength
and confidence as he begins to heal from
his past
unlike one division which waited into
the final few episodes to reveal that it
was agatha
all along the falcon in the winter
soldier establishes
its antagonists early on known as the
flag smashers these villains are
described
as longing for a time before hulk
brought back the missing half of the
earth's population
through coordinated attacks the faction
hopes to accumulate members so that they
can overtake the rest of society
and establish a new world without
borders in the debut episode of the
falcon and the winter soldier they rob a
bank in switzerland
all of them wearing menacing black masks
adorned with red handprints
so far the crew seems to be an
amalgamation of a group of marvel comics
baddies called
ultimatum and their villainous leader
the flagsmasher
known in the comics as carl morgenthau
this villain grew up with a disdain for
nationalism and the sense of superiority
that came with it
he made it his mission to abolish the
countries of the world so in order to
execute his vision he founded the
underground liberated totally integrated
mobile army to unite mankind but
that's a mouthful so it's just faster to
say ultimatum
they would go on and try to bring
flagsmasher's vision to life but the
group was often thwarted by both steve
rogers and john walker as captain
america
the falcon in the winter soldier is set
to feature aaron kellyman as a
gender-swapped version of the character
named carly morgenthau a female take on
the villain who is reportedly leading a
whole group of enemies who call
themselves
the flag smashers
hello girl kick your ass someone who
looks like she has kellyman's signature
red hair passes out flag smasher masks
to the assembled mob before his
assailant even shows up
hopefully we'll see more of her sooner
rather than later
the falcon and the winter soldier
introduces us to sam's sister
sarah wilson as well as her two sons at
their home in delacroix louisiana
it's made clear straight away that sam
and sarah come from a very tight knit
family and community but sarah doesn't
exactly approve of her brother's
lifestyle
not because she doesn't appreciate him
saving the world but because he hasn't
been the most helpful back home
even before he disappeared for five
years in the blip and now that he's back
she seems to resent his belief that he
has all the answers
nevertheless sam believes he and his
super heroic reputation can help sarah's
financial fortunes around with the new
bank loan
the rescue huh always
sarah reluctantly gives in since she
believes her only options are
selling their family fishing boat and
their childhood home
but when the wilson siblings head to the
local bank they refused a new loan
because
of the complication that came with half
of earth's population suddenly returning
to life after half a decade away
it's a frustrating heartbreaking scene
is there some kind of fun for heroes or
did stark pay you when he was around
the economics of being a superhero and
the unseen hardships that come with
being related to an avenger are rarely
touched on in marvel movies and series
it's just assumed that the billionaire
tony stark
the government or some other entity has
covered their expenses but that's
apparently not the case the revelation
that sam wilson can be a world-saving
hero and his sister sarah is still just
a normal struggling civilian
helps ground the falcon in the winter
soldier through real-life difficulties
people face
every day not only that but the family
dynamic between sam and sarah also feels
incredibly genuine
and in turn helps get viewers invested
in what they'll be up to as the series
progresses
will they save the family fishing boat
by the end of the series
stay tuned to find out in the closing
moments of the falcon in the winter
soldiers premiere episode
it's revealed that the united states
government had a plan for captain
america shield
all along and it's not to try to boost
attendance to the smithsonian
as in enraged sam wilson watches the new
captain america is unveiled on live
television armed with a shield that
falcon had just given up
based on sam's reaction to the news he
clearly didn't expect the us government
to make this move
and he seems to regret giving up the
shield in the first place
while we haven't heard him referred to
as anything other than your new captain
america yet
this incarnation of cap is john walker
more commonly known in marvel comics as
us agent a subject of experimentation by
the power broker
locker possesses similar abilities to
steve rogers including enhanced strength
speed and durability
and is an expert hand-to-hand combatant
he's the creation of mark grunwald and
paul neary and arrived in print in
november 1986's captain america number
323
in his first appearance walker is known
as the villainous super patriot
walker went on to adopt the captain
america name in captain america number
333
but when issue number 354 rolled around
he took on the alias of us agent which
he maintains in the comics to this day
is this new captain america a patriot
worthy of wielding the shield
or will this character mirror his
comic's counterpart as a more ruthless
tool of the american government
either way considering how close steve
and sam were and the mutual respect they
had for one another
it's a given jon and sam and probably
bucky
will clash sooner rather than later just
when their inevitable fight for the
captain america shield and steve's
legacy will come is a question that only
time can answer
we'll just have to see how the story of
the falcon and the winter soldier
unfolds check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the marvel cinematic
universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one